humans are great at innovating and
building stuff but when it comes to
figuring out what went wrong and how it
went wrong and fixing things it's much
better to have automation do that then
humans do that because we take our sweet
time with things and we also don't have
the mental power to process so much data
that's out there all at once machines
are much better at doing that you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using dr. bonnez ARS ani
is a senior researcher in the mobility
and networking group at MSR and she
feels your pain at least that is if
you're a network operator trying to
troubleshoot an incident in a data
center her research is all about getting
networks to manage themselves so your
life is as pain-free as possible on
today's podcast dr. oz ani tells us why
it's so hard to identify and resolve
networking problems and then explains
how content-aware or domain customized
auto ml frameworks might help she also
tells us what she means when she says
she wants to get humans out of the loop
and reveals how a competitive streak and
a comment from her high school principal
set her on the path to a career in high
tech research that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
banaz ARS ani welcome to the podcast hey
thanks for having me I like to start
situating mmm and you're a senior
researcher at MSR and you work in
mobility and networking but that falls
under the bigger umbrella of systems and
networking so to kick off our
conversation give us the elevator pitch
version of what you all are up to what's
the big goal of mobility and networking
and how does it fit into the broader
ecosystem of systems and networking
right so I guess mobility and networking
as the name suggests goes into two parts
of mobility and networking so half of
our groups are doing things like IOT
research edge research things that have
to do with mobile phones and things like
that or like devices and what people
like me do are more of the networking
aspect so every distributed system that
is out there has an underlying network
and so our job is to try to figure out
how to operate those networks properly
and how to make those networks work the
best way possible so what would you say
the big audacious goal of systems and
networking or mobility and networking is
sort of writ large so I think every
person you ask is going to give you a
different answer on that particular take
on this is that we're the infrastructure
behind a lot of the systems that you see
out there from the web that you access
to that storage systems that you use to
everything else and so our job is to
make this as seamless as possible so you
shouldn't even know that these networks
are there you should just use it and
expect that they work properly well
let's talk about what gets you up in the
morning and where you situate yourself
as a researcher what's your big gulp and
AHS as a scientist and what do you want
to be known for at the end of your
career yeah so when I think about this
and this was mainly after doing many
many internships and as you're
networking and seeing what operators
have to deal with every day and to me it
seems like the worthy goal or what I
really want to achieve is something
where the life of an operator and
network operator is as painless as
possible because it can get painful on
days especially if there's you know
something broke and they have to figure
out what happened it can be a nightmare
and what I would like to see is that
they don't have to do that
and we will get into how you're going
about that shortly let's start with one
of the things that is kind of
interesting to me many people I've
talked to on this podcast emphasized the
importance of keeping humans in the loop
but you suggest in some ways and for
some problems we actually need to get
humans out of the loop or at least you
question why after so many years you
still have so many humans trying to
figure so much of this all out so when
you say get humans out of the loop what
do you mean and then how does it play
out in the work you're doing right so I
think depends on what do you get the
humans out of the loop of to me humans
are great innovating and building stuff
but when it comes to figuring out what
went wrong and how it went wrong and
fixing things it's much better to have
automation do that then humans do that
because we take our sweet time with
things and we also don't have the mental
power to process so much data that's out
there all at once machines are much
better at doing that and what I keep
seeing is that we as humans are very
very inefficient and what that causes is
that our customers often are in pain
while humans are trying to figure things
out like that and so why do we have to
do that after so many years of having
networks out there and I think it's
because this particular problem is just
a really really hard problem to solve
yeah and so I find that both exciting
and hard and so it's a challenge that's
worth pursuing hasn't it gotten more
complicated rather than saying you know
we should have had this figured out by
now it's like well the internet threw us
a lot more problems the cloud has thrown
us a bigger problem how would you answer
that a lot of this has to do with scale
so we've just have more and more of
things and the bigger things are is
harder to handle but also our processing
capabilities have also increased so
that's a one piece of goodness the other
thing is like if you think of things
like cloud yes they did like throw us a
curveball in introducing something new
but also they added a little bit of
structure
so when you think about like a cloud
Network it's much more symmetric and
much easier to reason about compared to
something like the internet which is
just a hodgepodge of devices connected
to each other with arbitrary topologies
like if you look at the stuff we did in
double-oh-seven for example what we used
really was that the fixed structure and
the nice structure that cloud networks
actually have so that actually helped
that actually helps interesting ok cuz
you know you just think the bigger it is
the more messy it is but you're actually
saying it's added a layer of structure
yeah to help iron out some of the
problems all right well let's talk a
little bit more in detail about those
kinds of problems data centered
diagnosis is hard there's lots of
incidents lots of different kinds of
incidents incidents with whole life
cycles why is this so hard and what are
some specific research projects you have
going to make it not so hard yeah so if
you go back to what I was saying earlier
like the network is really the
underlying infrastructure a lot of a lot
of distributed systems so there's a lot
of dependency on a well-functioning
network but the problem is also that
when something goes wrong how do you
know if it's the network that's
problematic or if there's other layers
of the infrastructure that may be
problematic a very simple example of
this is all of the VMS we operate in
Azure are dependent on our storage
systems for example because they have a
virtual hard drive that has to access
those storage system so they have to go
over the network but there's also that
storage system itself that can fail it's
also the VM virtual hard disk that might
felt like there's a lot of different
failure scenarios that host make feel
the server might fail everything and so
what we see often is that well the first
step is to just locate who the expert is
that needs to look at this problem and
often it's the case that because there
are so many different levels of
expertise like the storage people the
storage or operator knows really well
how storage works but he may not know
anything about how a network works right
and so he doesn't know how to look at
this network and to determine whether
this network is healthy or not right so
we really need a network operator to get
engaged at that point but at the same
time you need to first know that you
need a network operator to that it's
kind of like a chicken-and-egg problem
you don't know what you don't know yeah
so the projects were working on right
now in the case of this storage example
that I gave I think in 2016 we had a net
poro project that dealt with that right
now we are looking at a project called
Scouts which its goal is basically to
say if each individual team provides an
abstraction that basically says is it
likely that my team is probably going to
be responsible for this problem so my
expertise is needed or not that way at
least a storage operator when it sees
that the storage system is failing can
know oh I need a networking expert or I
need a host expert an SDN expert what
type of expert do I need to help me with
figuring this out so the problem
upstream is diagnosing where the problem
is and you want to do that quickly right
so that you can address the issue and
the problem has been that with a human
it takes way too long to even figure out
who to blame right so what is it that
machines can do to help us out here
I think the observation at least we had
and there's a lot of work still
remaining to be done but the observation
is well we see enough examples as like
if I'm the networking team in Microsoft
we've seen examples of failures happen
in the past and we collect a lot of data
from our own infrastructure so the idea
is can we learn from past failures
whether this is probably going to be a
caused by a networking problem or a
physical networking problem for example
and basically use machine learning to
identify whether this problem is likely
due to this team's infrastructure
failing so these failures present
themselves in a certain way that would
be a pattern detection thing that would
be really good for machines - so for
example in the case of physical
networking that turns out to be really
true it's more complicated when you have
for example something like a software
load balancer is a lot more complicated
because it has a lot more dependencies
and it's failures are also more complex
so for certain teams this is easier but
the nice thing is also that for these
teams these are often the first ones to
get blamed anyway because all of the
teams depend on them right so it's kind
of like a win-win situation you might
want to build similar things for the
teams that you can build this for right
and then hope that this would simplify
the problem to an extent that it makes
the
my phone operators easier okay well talk
a little bit more about the lifecycle of
a problem because our an incident will
call it because we all recognize there
are incidents that are gonna happen and
there will be a lot of them when I have
this giant scale what do you mean when
you say lifecycle of an incident well so
an incident starts when some monitoring
infrastructure picked up that some
anomaly is happening and something is
not operating as it should and so an
incident is created a lot of other times
we also have automation that goes and
checks and knows how to fix it so that's
the good case that's like the best case
scenario but in some cases when
automation also fails to solve the
problem we have humans that are called
basically to try to resolve it and
basically the first step that that human
takes is to figure out who to call
to help and also they get together and
try to figure out ok which part of the
system went wrong how do we fix it and
the first step is actually mitigating
the problem meaning for example if I
have a software load balancer that's
problematic I'll redirect all of my
traffic to a different software load
balancer why I'll figure out what's
going on with this load balancer right
and then they go out proceed to fix it
and resolve the issue I'm having a
visual of an ER doc you know you triage
and you say you know is he breathing is
he bleeding start one stop the other
right and then we can move on to what's
really the problem exactly
yeah that's basically what happens
[Music]
well let's talk a little bit more about
automation for a second and this trend
towards Auto ml or automated machine
learning and it's one line of research
that seems really promising and there's
some specific branches of it you refer
to them as content-aware ml or domain
customized Auto ml frameworks right so
talk somewhat generally about the work
that's going on in ml and then tell us
how you are instantiating it in the
world of networks and distributed
sisters I mean I think this came up when
I was the only one in our group which
knew a little bit about networking and
machine learning and I had 30 different
teams in Azure asking me to build them
and she learning modeled something
whatever that was and it felt like the
pattern that I was going through each
time was very very similar and so it
felt like I should be able to replicate
my brain somehow so that like I'm not
needed in that process and I didn't know
at the time when I researched it I found
that Auto ml is actually a thing in the
machine learning communities I didn't
know that and then when I looked at
those what I found is that a lot of them
try to do anything and everything or
they're customized to domains that are
very very popular things like video
analytics like natural language
processing things like that are always
needed not necessarily something for
networking so my friend and I beetle
honey from burgers group started to look
at well what happens if you just dump
networking data into these systems like
just let's see how well they do and they
did is maleeh bad the state of the art
was like terrible and so we looked at it
and said okay why is that the case and
what we found was that well there's
simple domain customizations that we
could do even on the input not anything
to the machine learning but just how we
present the data that would
significantly boost their accuracy and
so the idea was well actually operators
are really good at that part like they
really know their data they really know
things about the data that the auto ml
frameworks don't know so is there a way
to bridge this gap is there a way to
provide that domain knowledge without
knowing anything about ml maybe like
somehow the auto ml framework knows what
information it needs and queries for
that information from the user and the
user provides that information
and then we use that to generate more
customized ml model as part of those
Auto ml frameworks so this sounds a lot
like Patrice Amar's work in machine
teaching which is similar to this
domain-specific ml right
I mean it's similar and yet different I
think the nice thing about networking is
actually even though the types of
problems we tackle are very very diverse
they fall into a very limited set of
categories things like congestion
control like diagnosis like traffic
engineering like I can count them on my
hand how many broad problem topics
should we tackle and so because of that
is much easier to provide a networking
specific abstraction for these systems
than it is for any generic problem and
again like for example a network has a
specific structure you always have
underlying topology like there are
things we know right where for generic
problems we might not know those
specific topics and I think that's where
like our take on the problem is
different in the sense that we want to
exploit Network specific domains that
you can quantify almost right like you
can use a structure for them as opposed
to like a generic problem so you're
providing a domain expert in networking
with machine learning tools and they
don't necessarily have to be a machine
learning expert to be able to use these
tools to make the whole thing yeah I
should preface that that we don't know
how to do this like I'm just like giving
you the idea this is what we want to do
we don't know how to do it yet okay go
in there a little bit you don't know how
to do this so this is a like an idea
okay where are you with the idea how far
have you pushed we did initially was
just to verify this hypothesis that
domain knowledge actually helps Auto
systems and we were successfully able to
demonstrate that what we're doing now is
take one specific area in networking
that's very very well structured but yet
rich in problems specifically congestion
control so if in congestion control you
might have a lot of different problems
what is the best congestion control
protocol for me to use as I think given
point in time given different objective
functions that I have or like can I
design an ml based congestion control
protocol and a lot of different are
there questions that we have a whole
list of
idea is well how do we build a domain
customized ottoman law framework for
congestion control specifically so it's
not even for networking just wear this
very very tiny domain within networking
and we're exploring whether we can do
that okay thank you for the word
hypothesis it was the one I was
searching for and couldn't find five
minutes ago you have a paper that just
got accepted at the conference for
networked systems design and
implementation and SDI this year and you
call it Private Eye and it deals with
scalable and privacy preserving
compromised detection in the cloud what
problem is this work addressing and
what's promising about your approach to
it so the problem was really when we
talk to our operators one of the things
they mentioned is we have these really
good compromised detection systems that
are very very effective that customers
can use but they don't want to use boy
or I don't know if like don't want to
use might be a strong word it might be
that they are hesitant to use and the
reason for that seems to be that they're
concerned about their privacy how much
data they want to share with Microsoft
and also taking on a third party code so
basically Microsoft would have to
maintain that compromised detection
system ploy them and a lot of customers
aren't comfortable with that right so we
looked at this and the idea was well we
still need to protect all of our
customers even though they won't don't
necessarily want to use a system so how
do we do this without needing our
customers permission to do so and the
observation was and this is not a new
observation a lot of researchers have
made this observation in the past which
is well network behavior changes one of
them is compromised so can we use that
change to basically say whether it be M
is likely to be compromised or not and
then go from there the other observation
which is unique to this paper was though
that we do have these compromised
detection systems that are very very
effective and they're running on at
least our first party VMs and these are
vm's that run things like being like
sequel like services that we have and
some of our customers are also opting in
to use them so what they do is provide a
constant stream of detections of
compromised VMs that they've seen and we
can use those as sort of quote unquote
labels to learn okay this is
what compromise looks like and this is
what changes it induces in the network
behavior of these VMs putting these two
on top of each other we were like okay
maybe we can do something that's privacy
preserving compromised detection that
operates a data center scale Wow and
then scale is also a hard thing here so
the paper goes into a lot of trouble of
explaining for example how do I ensure
that I can run at this massive scale
without sacrificing too much and I
accuracy without having to use things
like IP addresses whether right now with
DDP are difficult to use because gdpr
says that if a customer wants to they
can contact you and say that you have to
delete this and you have 24 hours to do
so as well so this sounds like it is
also in the sort of early stages of how
might we do this yes basically goes in
demonstrates that we can theoretically
do this and my experience with the other
Scout project kind of says that there's
a whole nine yards between we think we
can do this and we deploy it and we say
oh this came up so we know this and then
this other thing so like what I found
actually very interesting is from
research paper to actually deployment
things can change 180 degrees like you
might just completely change the
approach you use just because new
constrains come up in deployment that
you hadn't thought about when you are
doing the prototype version which is
basically what the paper usually is but
you're moving forward and this paper is
kind of the beginning of the exploration
and then you're gonna try to scale it up
and see where it breaks yeah it probably
will break yeah but that's what research
is about right
well you just referred to scout again
and let's preface this by saying
collaboration is so essential to
research now that Microsoft Research
even has an award for it and you
recently won this you and your team
recently won it for this project called
Scout so tell us about the project what
is Scout and why did it win MSRs
collaboration award that's interesting
so I started Scout two years ago with an
intern of mine who was from Princeton
and we basically first started to think
about okay is this even a problem like
the first step is like how bad is this
problem and is this really a problem to
find this problem meaning is it really
the case that we will find it hard to
blame a team for a problem we did that
investigation and say yeah apparently it
is hard so let's try to solve this
problem wait wait wait so for me it's
easy to blame okay let's just like level
set here you're saying it's hard to
blame a team or it's hard to prove the
blame well everybody points to figure
out the other one right so that's
basically what happens because also like
you know people have limited time so
they do a superficial check and if
everything seems healthy was like no not
me you're right your turn passing the
ball around until somebody figures out
what's going on and that is very very
inefficient okay basically just
demonstrated that that's the case all
right then we were like okay how do we
solve this problem and so we went about
at least doing a prototype version of
the Scout which is basically a paper we
submitted and fine but then we were like
okay can we actually deploy this and
there's this really cool project in the
systems group going on called resource
central which has to do with a framework
to deploy machine learning models in
production so that's where Ricardo
Bianchini came in and said well we have
this really cool framework why don't you
guys take advantage of this and use this
to deploy the system so they helped us
to basically deploy the first version of
a skelet and then the physical
networking team in Azure was the first
team that we targeted to build a scout
for and they helped us with insights on
what they knew about the network the
data they collected
helped us figure out okay do you did a
great job here you did a sucky job here
you can hate you for it and all of those
different things so like they provided
us with really good feedback right and
this is an ongoing collaboration so we
found that Scouts do really well in
certain cases but they suck at cases
where operators get actually angry about
like right we can classify really really
hard problems when it comes to the easy
stuff we sometimes make mistakes and it
turns out operators don't like it when
you get things wrong that they would
have gotten right you can't have
everything though come on guys well
here's a question though is the easy
stuff problem like the person who's
proofreading a paper and gets all of the
small print right but the headline has a
massive error in it pretty much yeah so
like for example like one example we saw
is there was an instant where the title
of the incident said arista switch this
is experiencing problem so a split is
basically the purview of the physical
networking team he's actually saying
this is what the problem is our very
cool Scouts this is not a physical
networking issue okay why turns out that
that particular incident was a transient
problem so that meant that there was a
blip and that blip really didn't
register in the monitoring data that we
had the machine learning model thought
things are fine nothing's passing but
because we didn't have the contextual
information and this goes back to the
need for contacts right like we didn't
have the contextual information and so
we got that one wrong and what we
learned from that is well we need to
have some form of contextual features as
part of our feature set now if you look
at our prototype version this really
didn't register to us as an important
problem because our accuracy was so high
we had like 98% true positive 97% to
negative but in that 3% we had these
very very simple mistakes that operators
are very unforgiving about because it's
like it's saying it in the title
so how do you fix that well so it
actually ends up being in relatively
simple fix because again like it's in
the title you just use information from
the title as part of the features that
you're using for us the original
hypothesis was use the monitoring data
as God basically what does the data show
hmm but also it's a fact that you know
there are some incidents that turn out
to be non problems but there's still an
incident and somebody has to still go
and look so it's important to basically
have the contacts from the incident
itself as well as part of your feature
set okay so I want to sort of weave back
in some of the things we've talked about
my understanding of what you want to
accomplish here is a self managing
network using auto ml frameworks and
having as little human slowdown in the
process as possible you don't want
humans completely out of the loop I mean
ideally you would want to and I think
that's like kind of the Holy Grail do
you foresee a future where that would be
possible somebody that I really admire
once told me when you build systems you
have to ask yourself can it take me to
Mars and I think that's pretty much what
we fail to do when building now recently
because there's maybe I don't know but
when I look at a lot of the work I have
done and a lot of work my peers have
done I think we never really asked
ourselves that question which is where I
were in the mess we're in right maybe
over time as we start to ask that
question more will it take us to Mars
then because you know we are the same
people that built actual things that
took us through the moon right and those
did not need operators to manage them
yeah well okay but so having the
contextual input for these systems to
identify the stupid errors can you do
that and make that happen with the
machine without having the human context
provided the right answer to that
question is I don't know these are
things that were experimenting with that
we're trying but who knows all right
let's bring this all together your big
goal is to get to networks that can
manage themselves and we're not there
yet so what would you say are the big
open problems in the field that if
solved would get us closer to the
network equivalent of self-driving cars
so I think there's a couple of things
one is what data do we actually need
from the network to be able to do this I
think that's still an open problem but
the problem is not that we don't know
what exactly do we need is like what
data we need and how to efficiently
collect it like how do we collect it
without actually breaking the network
while doing so I think that's like
there's a lot of work going on and we
see paper after paper on this topic but
we really don't know what is the
necessary and sufficient data set to be
able to do this that's one the control
loops that we need to be able to then
use this data to do self-driving
networks and self-driving the cool end
of self-driving cars is I don't think
they're in place yet and we don't even
have the mechanisms to then implement
that control loop yet I also think that
we've been bogged down by just how to
get the network to work in the first
place and a lot of the papers that we
see like for example the traffic
engineering papers we see how to do with
that and so I think it's just we haven't
had time yet to fully explore the other
side of things and networks themselves
like you started talking about Internet
of Things and Donald Cosman was recently
on the podcast and talked about nine
billion things and trying to think of
how you even wrap your brain around how
you would manage that kind of a network
that's your business well we've talked
about what gets you up in the morning
and it's a lot that gets you up in the
morning now I want to know what keeps
you up at night and I often joke with
some researchers that their entire
career is about what keeps them up at
night technically speaking that said is
there anything about your work outside
the fact that it's important to get your
work right that keeps you up at night
metaphorically and if so how are you
dealing with it so I guess
this is more recent I don't think it's
been the case for the past like whatever
years is like after we started actually
deploying the skeleton getting it to use
in production like my worry is again
will it get us to Mars for lack of a
better word in the sense of how
trustworthy is it when is it gonna break
again how long is it gonna last as is
when is the next time that somebody's
gonna yell at me because I got a simple
thing wrong so I think reliability of
machine learning systems for networking
and how hands-free can they actually be
is something that keeps me up at night
because it seems to me at least with our
experience that there's some level of
hand-holding that's needed over time and
that worries me because what does that
actually mean does it mean that you
always need somebody babysitting these
types of systems and that's not
necessarily the best thing that you
would want yeah you got me thinking so
deeply right now
oh well the preferred future and humans
out humans in and if we could ever
really get to a full representation of
data center problems that's why you're
working here well it's storytime Banias
tell us about yourself how did you get
started in the high tech life and how
did you end up at Microsoft Research I
heard the word internships in high
school I loved physics and I liked two
circuits an electrical system so I went
into Electrical Engineering as my
bachelor's degree and still I liked
Electrical Engineering a lot like I was
the circus person the analog circuits
person how do you analyze at that time
they would teach us things about bjts
and such and then that was where I
wanted to go and a friend of mine said
you'll never find a job in electrical
engineer Willie yeah especially in
analog circuits which I was particularly
good at and so I was like okay what's
the next thing I'm good at and that was
probability and networking I'm like okay
that's what I'm gonna do and actually
the first few classes that I sat
and because there was an electrical
engineering analog circuits class that
was in parallel to the digital signal
processing class that we had to take if
we weren't in the communications major
and I was sit in that class and I was I
have to be in that other class and then
I started to fall in love with it I was
like I really really like networking so
I applied to a networking ph.d again
intellectual engineering and then my
advisor has just left my school so I had
to find a new advisor and that was in
the computer science department and
that's how I became a computer scientist
accident circuitous route yes and then I
loved it so like most of it is like I
accidentally stumbled into where I'm at
and then I ended up falling in love with
it where did it all start I mean where
was this taking place and who are you
working with so I was at the University
of Pennsylvania I was working with rock
Darin when I started and then rock left
to become the chair of computer science
at Washington st. Louis so then I moved
to computer science to work with my new
advisor Boone talu who was still there
and I did networking and then I think my
first internship was in 2015 here in
Azure network not Microsoft Research No
and then again I loved it so I came back
for a second time and then I applied for
a postdoc here I did a postdoc and then
I applied for full-time jobs and then
the rest is history
so postdoc in Azure or postdoc in
Microsoft Research okay I don't think
Ezra has postdocs I actually fought for
a postdoc advisor and they said that we
don't have such right tell me a little
bit though about the back and forth
between Asher and Microsoft Research so
the way it happens in MSR is very
different than the way to happen in
Azure so when I was an azure intern
I talked to Azure people every day 24
hours a day so I knew about all of the
problems where we're going on I knew
what people's pain points are because
they were sitting next to me here at MSR
people come to us and say I need this
problem solved or we solve a problem
like hey we solve this problem do you
actually need and so it's very very
different I would say the dynamic of
going from a idea
our two actually deploying it in
production mm-hmm and it's much much
harder than if you come up with the idea
when you're sitting in Azure and
deploying it in Azure but it's amazing
how easily it gets done it's amazing
like how fun the collaborations are
anyone from your position now where do
you see yourself in the future
staying in research I prefer to not
think about that type of thing I like to
be the person who does things while
they're fun and once they're not fine
stop doing them and move on to the next
thing so I have no idea how to answer
that question all right well tell us
something that we might not know about
you maybe it impacted your life or
career a life defining moment or some
personal characteristic but maybe it's
just something interesting that would
give us some context about you outside
the lab okay
not something I'm really proud of but
I'm a very very competitive person so I
always attribute me getting to where I
am - a friend of mine in high school
where our principal would come and say
learn from this person this person is
great and I was like I can do better and
it's sad for true that the reason I'm
here is because of a competition with
another person in high school otherwise
I would not get into college I think I
would not get to where I am okay so let
me clarify there was an actual person
that your principal said be like that
person and I was like no I'm gonna be
better than that person oh my gosh click
to meet that principal well before we go
I want to give you the opportunity to
talk to some version of your grad school
self assuming you'd listen to you what
advice would you give yourself if you
could go back and give yourself advice
the advice I would think is it's okay to
be nitpicky like I think one thing that
I found frustrating as a PhD student was
how much one of my advisers Rock wanted
us to be very very meticulous about
making sure about every single detail
about something
before we made a conclusion and it took
a long time to do it was a lot of pain
and I've now learned to appreciate that
and so what I would say is it's hard now
but it's such good advice but now's ours
on e thank you for joining us today it's
so much fun I know
[Music]
to learn more about dr. bonnez are sunny
and the latest in networking research
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]